apparently being called out by the
mueller team wasn't enough
appearing on the ironically named
reliable sources show sunday
one of the authors of the buzzfeed piece
triple down
i have further confirmation that this is
right we're being told to stay in
our ground this is this is our reporting
is going to be borne out to be accurate
and um
we're 100 behind it what if what if the
sources are just wrong
they're not not intentionally not trying
to hurt you but just
what if they're wrong they're not
they're not i'm confident
a follow-up there here now exclusively
and his very first appearance on the
ingram angle is donald trump jr don
thanks so much for being here
tonight uh uh when this story first came
out you know reporters were
quick to pounce quick to turn the
spotlight on you
well they they always are laura and this
isn't the first time that happened you
saw it right after i did my testimony
and they said oh
donald trump jr had the wikileaks
information because presumably adam
schiff leaked it right after my
testimony
uh to them and conveniently took out the
one before the four
turning the 14th into the fourth meaning
i had it six days since
you know before the world saw it as
opposed to four days after the entire
world saw it
this has gone on time and time again
it also happened when lanny davis said
something along the effect of i told my
father about the russia meeting and he
was there
he was cnn's source he then walked it
back and realized it was totally wrong
their own source did it
and yet today they still haven't pulled
that back
and the reason is they need it to be
true laura
they've been pushing this nonsense for
two
years they've found nothing but any time
there's a negative
any time there's a chance to get trump
they're gonna jump on it
they're basically leftists policing
leftists at this point i love watching
some of the cnn commentary
well this is going to give us all a bet
of course it is because you
jump on it each and every time you know
they they cover themselves with the well
if true
if true well if you're not sure it's
true don't push it for 14 hours you have
to see it 2 p.m on friday don
this is what they were going with at cnn
what about the the family here i mean
when you read this buzzfeed piece it's
ivanka
trump and don jr who are implicated don
jr testified to congress in september of
17
saying he was quote unquote his words
peripherally aware of it
afterwards democrats chris coons and
jackie spears said it is possible that
he lied
how much jeopardy could these family
members be well i think that's what we
have to wait and see what happens and if
family members of trump
are going to be implicated that could be
a reason for him to resign and try to
work out a deal uh to save his family
don they were going to right to
impeachment then to resignation
i mean they got him this time laura you
know like the other 75 times because
they haven't exactly panned out by the
way
no different than the story you covered
at the beginning right you had
some catholic school boys that were at a
right to life march okay they were
wearing a maga hat
they had to pounce because the media
wants that to be true
they want a bunch of nice catholic kids
happen to be white they want them to be
the enemy
this is what they've created the media
has done this to themselves
they have shot themselves in the foot
time and time again
because they so desperately want this to
be the truth as opposed to
saying you know what trump has done a
darn good job as president
if you look at any economic metric today
laura we are substantially
better off than we were two short years
ago before he took office
because he's doing a great job imagine
what he could do without the noise
without the oh every day there's a new
reason for impeachment let him do his
job
that's the job he was elected to do and
the media right now
is really trying to subvert this
democracy they've done more to hurt the
credibility
of this country's institution as a
democracy than anything in history not
only the president but anyone
who supports the president doesn't
matter if you're 14 or you're my age or
if
you've you've so it doesn't matter laura
because that must make you all sorts of
things
donnie the the issue with this trump
tower thing keeps coming back
keeps coming back keeps coming back and
we know the buzzfeed
feed deal and and they claim they have
it's all sourced and everything
of course you've had time to think about
this you testified when was the last
discussion about this trump tower deal
because rudy got everybody really
confused i have to say
and i love rudy he hasn't been on the
show in a while we love him but he goes
on meet the press and he says
well it could have been like right
through the election then he said he was
talking
in hypothetical terms today yeah
i don't know i i don't talk about things
that i don't know about but you know
unfortunately that sometimes happens
no different than anyone else but the
reality is this wasn't a deal
you know i don't think we don't know the
developer we don't know the site
we don't know the anything about it
ultimately was michael cohen essentially
trying to get a deal done you know he
was there for a long time he wasn't
exactly a deal guy didn't bring too many
to the table so i don't think anyone
took it all that seriously
that's the reality of what went on but
you know it's that constant link now we
got him you saw the story last week you
know donald trump is a russian agent
yeah
the guy that's a billionaire leading in
a pretty incredible lifestyle he left
all of that to go into this snake pit
to go into the swamp to run against 16
17 republican contenders he's got zero
chance of doing that
to then defeat hillary clinton he had
zero chance of doing that
uh you know he did all this because he's
a russian agent i mean
the reason the media has no credibility
is because this is what they do
this is what they do to themselves adam
schiff who has the
ability now to call witnesses of course
he does
set he he he isn't going to stop
buzzfeed report no buzzfeed report
and i want to play something for you and
get your reaction
are you still going to investigate the
claims absolutely absolutely congress
has a as a fundamental interest
uh in two things first uh in getting to
the bottom of why a witness came before
us and lied
uh and who else was knowledgeable that
this was a lie
even though it's been debunked don he's
going to proceed i imagine he's going to
call you back
yeah he's got nothing to reality he's
got nothing else there's a 99.9
chance he's the guy that was leaking my
testimony as i was testifying i came out
of testimony at about eight o'clock at
night looking
and cnn is running quotes from noon on
about my testimony
you know in the house intelligence
committee i mean that has to say
something
about what's going on in there since
he's never met a camera he didn't love
i i would bet a lot of money that it was
him and the reality is
i've done 25 hours of testimony on a
20-minute meeting
this has been the greatest witch hunt in
american history perhaps
perhaps world history in three hours
they found the bomber that was the fake
bomber
and in two years they haven't found
anything other than
they got a big bombshell oh it's they
got trump this time
i've heard it too many times laura the
american people don't take this stuff
seriously anymore they look at these
people like jokers at this point
kamala harris was out there today you
know she's announcing that she announces
she's going to run for president
let's listen the path is going to be
about
talking to people who are right now
aware that this economy is not working
for working people
it's going to be about talking with
people about the fact that right now we
have an administration
that has waged a full-on assault on
american values and american ideals
now don when you hear a sitting senator
say
an assault on american values and
american ideals
your dad's called a racist i've known
him for 20 years
i'm sorry the insanity is there you saw
this with the social media platforms
attacking the word
family because god forbid you have
family right
uh you know this is this leftist assault
when you talk about
this economy not working for the
american working class
i mean donald trump's the first
president to speak to the american
worker
in generations at this point he's the
guy
delivering it as i said earlier there's
not a single economic metric where we
are not better off as a country today
than we were two years ago under barack
obama the media
carrying the democrats baggage they'll
say whatever they want they should be
paid as lobbyists of the dnc at this
point
are you now still thinking politics in
the future i mean
it's been thought that you were going to
go into politics something listen i i
haven't thought about it that way
for me it's about you know right now
whatever i can do to help my father win
i'm going to do because i love what's
going on as an american as a patriot as
a father of five young children
i see what he's doing what he's fighting
and the nonsense barrage that he's
taking from the insanity that has become
the left let's not kid ourselves
this is not your grandfather's
democratic party they've really lost
their way
they have no interest in protecting
americans only
pushing and furthering their insane
agenda
and i'm gonna do what i can to help him
whatever happens in the future i'll deal
with that then but in the meantime
uh he's making it pretty easy uh
given what he's doing because he's doing
a phenomenal job for this country
2020 is coming already there are all
lining up don thanks so much don't be a
stranger thanks for coming on
i'll be back